Egyptian warplanes bomb Islamic State-controlled sites in Libya...
...hours after a video emerged...
...showing the apparent beheading of 21 Egyptian Coptic Christians.
In Denmark, police say they have detained two men suspected of helping a gunman...
...who murdered two people in separate Copenhagen shootings Saturday.
In the US, the UN Security Council demands Shiite Houthi rebels in Yemen...
...restore the Sana'a government and immediately release US-backed president...
...Abed Rabbo Mansour Hadi and his ministers.
In India, Sri Lanka and India sign a civil nuclear agreement,...
...which leaders call a sign of trust between the two nations.
And finally from Ukraine, Ukraine's government and Russian-backed rebels...
...are accusing each other of violating a ceasefire...
...intended to end the fighting in eastern Ukraine.